ah
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24
soy herminia fernández comenzamos
el 18 de marzo de 1962 francia y argelia
firmaron unos acuerdos de alto el fuego
que abrieron la vía hacia la
independencia de argelia
concertados a duras penas los acuerdos
estuvieron seguidos por un período de
transición
particularmente violento la organización
armada secreta o 'las que rechazó esos
pactos aplicó una estrategia de tierra
arrasada que precipitó la partida de
cientos de miles de pie no a los
franceses de argelia el proyecto de una
argelia multicultural se hizo a pedazos
en medio del dolor 60 años después los
reporteros de france24 se encontraron
con los testigos y actores de un momento
central en la historia de ambos países a
continuación el reportaje de karim
rihaui nesrim vence buzzi y george
yazbek
[Música]
un suntuoso edificio al borde del
tranquilo lago leman
esta residencia privada solía ser el
hotel du pack no le identifica ninguna
placa y sin embargo aquí se vivió un
momento decisivo en la historia franco
argelina
hay un sol y fernet del hotel y bajó la
temperatura https sanando el proyecto y
tuve que hacer en la delegación del ente
louis jacques y la delegación francesa
santonja wind flojo tv puede ser fue por
concluido la paz
finalmente después de siete años y medio
de guerra cruel e interminable
sin embargo muchos esperaban que
terminara antes
la fecha de transición clave en esta
historia para francia es 1959 el 16 de
septiembre de 1959 de gaulle apareció en
televisión afirmando que nos orientamos
hacia el autodeterminación
me comprometo a consultar a los asilos
de sus doce departamentos
sobre el destino que quieren adoptar
y eso se entendió en ese momento como
una marcha hacia la independencia yo era
un niño cuando enviaron a mi padre como
profesor a argelia
fui subteniente en argelia durante la
guerra y el 19 de septiembre de 1959
pensamos que había terminado pero como
sabe las negociaciones de evian sólo
empezaron a concluirse durante la
primavera de 1962
cuando el padre pierre georges louis
jacques encabezó la delegación francesa
que negoció los acuerdos de evian pero
entre la declaración del general de
gaulle y los acuerdos de alto el fuego
se duplicó la intensidad de la guerra
entre 1959 y 1961 el plan del general de
gaulle tuvo por objetivo imponer la
potencia militar francesa sobre los
combatientes del ejército de liberación
nacional pero de gol realmente podría
haber acelerado el paso en el camino
hacia la paz
el general no podía fíjense en cómo
llegó al poder llegó al poder por unos
generales en nombre de la argelia
francesa si en ese momento tomaba esa
posición habría habido un golpe de
estado en francia
sin embargo las negociaciones
continuaron en ese contexto de violencia
extrema el ejército francés acumulaba
victorias militares pero resultaba cada
vez más difícil defender políticamente
la guerra de argelia en
1961 en evian no muy lejos de la
frontera con suiza se llevó a cabo una
nueva ronda de negociaciones que
despertó esperanzas en el territorio
suizo con reputación de neutralidad el
fmln encontró una base de retaguardia
adecuada para las discusiones con las
autoridades francesas y me llamo andre
agassi y llegué a suiza en 1960 de una
manera un poco particular - al soft
bienvenida porque acababa de desertar y
me encontré a otros camaradas
refractarios de
andrew gas un desierto espantado por la
tortura encontró refugio en suiza donde
fue encontrado por la televisión pública
o sociedad
en 1961 logré que me admitiera en
badajoz
donde había una delegación del gobierno
provisional de la república argelina
estaban los negociadores del gp era que
habían llegado un avión swisher desde
túnez
y vivían en boada
un lugar custodiado por el ejército
suizo por temor a un bombardeo de un
pequeño avión de lado a ese claro lo es
no hay que olvidar que el alcalde de
evian acababa de ser asesinado por las
personas de la argelia francesa
felicitas al cine
continúa la investigación para tratar de
encontrar a los autores del atentado de
dianga que le costó la vida al alcalde
de la ciudad el señor cam england y dejó
heridas en los investigadores examinan
actualmente algunos documentos del
expediente toda clase de cartas de
amenaza casi todas enviadas desde a
celia
así que un lunes 5 de junio yo estaba
delante de los negociadores era bastante
increíble estar frente a ellos la
alegría frente a los negociadores
la alegría
tal vez esa guerra podría terminar
negociación pero las primeras
negociaciones de elián no dieron
resultado
me llamo earl rowland y acá
en esa época estaba en el ministerio de
asuntos argelinos cuyo titular era luis
c
los acuerdos se desarrollaron en varias
fases
el caso estableció dos líneas rojas la
unidad del pueblo que se oponía a que
hiciéramos un estatuto especial para las
piernas
y luego la unidad de territorio bajo
ningún caso debíamos desmembrar angelia
privándola de sus departamentos
saharianos
el primer acuerdo no funcionó porque nos
aferramos a eso pero apenas fracasó fue
el golpe de estado
la perspectiva de una argelia
independiente era inconcebible para
algunos oficiales del ejército francés
en abril de 1961 trataron de derrocar el
poder colista
les habla el ejército
delante de ustedes están los generales
salió y se lea
el 13 de mayo del ejército francés juró
solemnemente mantener a argelia dentro
de la soberanía francesa
venimos hoy en nombre del ejército
francés a renovar ese juramento
los golpistas nunca lograron movilizar a
las tropas
todos tenían transistores
escuchaban lo que se decía en parís
los llamados del general a resistir
contra ese golpe
por eso fracasó
después de eso el general nos convocó y
nos dijo
argelia es una caja de penas pero tienen
alguna opinión sobre el futuro de la
negociación
yo sí tenía algo que decir los argelinos
nunca renunciarán al sáhara deben tener
la soberanía y si no la tienen no
funcionará quedé gratamente sorprendido
cuando escuché la conferencia de prensa
que dio unos días después en la que dijo
quién podría pensar que los angelinos
algún día renunciarían a la soberanía
sobre el sáhara
estamos listos para reconocerlas pero
necesitamos garantías
el acuerdo sobre el tema del sahara
desbloqueo unas negociaciones que una
vez más amenazaban con llegar a un punto
muerto el general de gaulle presionaba
cada vez más a sus negociadores el alto
el fuego se firmó el 18 de marzo de 1962
y entró en vigor el día siguiente al
mediodía
argelia la ciudad a la fuerza
[Música]
una simple transferencia de soberanía
con túnez o en marruecos aquí fue muy
difícil
los argelinos también obtuvieron una
sentencia favorable sobre un tema
fundamental para ellos no habría un
estatus particular para los europeos
querían darle la nacionalidad argelina a
un millón de europeos
pero manteniendo la nacionalidad
francesa eso generaba un estado dentro
del estado así que rechazamos ese punto
un referéndum de autodeterminación se
organizó en los tres meses siguientes
nació una argelia donde se garantizaría
la igualdad de derechos para los
ciudadanos
y quiso
y la perspectiva que se abre sobre el
advenimiento de un ángel independiente
que coopere estrechamente con nosotros
satisface la razón de francia
francia obtuvo una concesión de 15 años
sobre la base militar de mercè el kébir
y pudo continuar sus experimentos
nucleares en el sahara hasta 1966 por
otro lado argelia pasó a ser la
propietaria de las intensas reservas de
petróleo del país pero francia las
administro durante varios años la firma
de los acuerdos fue un inmenso alivio
para la metrópolis por un lado estoy muy
contento porque pronto me voy a hacer mi
servicio militar y creo que todo eso
habrá terminado antes pienso que era lo
único que deberíamos hacer es una
pesadilla que se está acabando desde
hace siete años teniendo en cuenta lo
que ha durado ha sido un poco largo es
un bien es un mal mi familia está en
argelia
si temo por ellos sí señor
el temor del poder gaullista era que se
reanudará la guerra de argelia
entonces animaron a sus representantes
en esas negociaciones
a que se dieran todo lo más rápido
posible sin compensaciones reales
y sin tener los medios ni tomarse el
tiempo para organizar una transición a
un estado
anita por su parte el fmln permaneció
atento el alto el fuego no era todavía
precisamente la paz
porque vimos la violencia de la s
cuando se firmaron los acuerdos hubo una
oleada de violencia inaudita en argelia
la oae se multiplicó los atentados y los
asesinatos el fmln respondió con
crímenes y secuestros los comandos de la
organización armada secreta se
enfrentaron con el ejército francés en
una sangrienta guerra de guerrillas
urbanas
en orán atacada por los comandos de lado
a s las tropas respondieron en las
estrechas calles la crs que establecían
sus divisiones fueron atacadas desde las
terrazas se contabilizaron 30 muertos y
66 heridos el 26 de marzo una
manifestación pro a ese se degeneró en
entrada del barrio bab el cuello
[Música]
el balance fue importante decenas de
muertos y un cambio en el espíritu de
muchos
hicimos que los franceses le dispararan
al ejército francés entonces para los
pierna azul esa fue la prueba de que el
abad tenía razón cuando decía es la
mochila o la tumba
los acuerdos prometían una argelia
multicultural pero durante ese periodo
de transición entre mayo y junio de 1962
cientos de miles de franceses huyeron de
argelia en junio el fmln y la oae se
terminaron de firmar un acuerdo que se
desdijo rápidamente y a pesar del
llamado del fmln el éxodo de los pie de
noa continuó irremediablemente
argelinos de origen europeo el nombre de
todos sus hermanos argelinos les quiero
decir que si así lo quieren las puertas
de futuro se abrirán tanto para ustedes
como para nosotros nuestro pueblo con su
sabiduría ha soportado muchas pruebas
que esta noche que mañana
es en las últimas violencias pero las
violencias continuaron incluso hasta el
mismo día de la independencia el
referendo previsto por los acuerdos de
evian fue una formalidad más del 99 por
ciento de los votantes escogieron la
independencia pero el 5 de julio la
fiesta nacional en orán terminó en luto
hubo disparos se desató el pánico la oae
se fue la principal sospechosa en el
corazón de la ciudad mientras la emoción
alcanza su punto máximo estalló un
tiroteo que dejó más de 100 muertos y
alrededor de 150 heridos entre las dos
comunidades
después del tiroteo hubo una oleada de
violencia muchos europeos fueron
linchados francia también dejó atrás
decenas de miles de jarquín
argelinos reclutados como auxiliares del
ejército francés que lucharon del lado
del colonizador considerados traidores
por el fmln
y los dejaron voluntariamente ahí
algunos dijeron haber renunciado
a esos los repartieron a francia y los
ubicaron en campamentos
porque
porque no confiaban en ellos
el general le ordenó a ellos
dan instrucciones para que no se
embarcará a los arcos
y
dijo esos harkins son personas que harán
desastres en francia
no quiero que vuelvan
me llamo flow y mohamed el stia
mohamed fluir creyó que podía quedarse
estuvo seis años en prisión antes de
poder entrar a francia
creí en los acuerdos de libia no creía
que todo estaba garantizado sabía que si
venía a francia tenía derecho a traer a
mi mujer ya mis hijos pero no a mi madre
ni a mis hermanos y hermanas
grité
entonces pensé que tal vez estaría bien
me quedé el 19 de marzo y el 22 de julio
de 1962 todo el mundo estaba en prisión
hubo muertos la mayoría murieron
de gauge abandono a los hearts que él
nos envió al corredor de la muerte
aunque los acuerdos de debian marcaron
el final de la guerra en argelia no
fueron reconocidos por el futuro poder
argelino y en particular por los
militares que vieron en ellos una marca
de la persistencia el colonialismo del
lado francés no fueron más que el medio
precipitado para salir de una guerra que
se había vuelto demasiado impopular
estos son los acuerdos de viana son
siete u ocho páginas todo esto era un
proyecto magnífico que habría podido
entrar en vigor en los años cuarenta
cincuenta tal vez sesenta
pero se echó a perder por dudas y
retroceso ción crímenes de ambas partes
desde que
los argelinos alcanzaron su
independencia y en los rostros de una
juventud radiante se leían las
esperanzas de vivir en una nación
emergente pero la sociedad multicultural
prometida en los acuerdos de evian sólo
existió en unas cuantas páginas de un
documento en el que nadie creyó
realmente
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]